good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to build
a great team over to you candy bars
[Music]
always good if you if you can get
somebody to partner up with you and with
other businesses because for me I have a
business partner with tags my stores
have business partner with bedroom kandi
if it wasn't for that I wouldn't be able
to do all the things that I'm doing but
because I do have great business
partners they helped me keep those
things going you know so you have to
have a great team you by yourself
probably won't work you can't be but in
so many places at one time so you have
to have people to see your vision and
you know help make your vision happen
you can't do everything yourself
if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur there are only so many
hours in the day and you only have so
much limited ability that if you try to
do everything in your business and never
look the scale to grow then you're going
to be limited and how much you can do
and how much you can accomplish now at
the start you do everything yourself at
the start you bootstrap you hustle you
find ways but quickly you need to figure
out what is the thing that you are among
the best people in the world at or have
that world-class potential you are
genius level talent at something what is
that figure that out and spend as much
time in that Lane as possible and then
look to expand by building up people
we're great with all the things that
you're not good at here a couple of
pitfalls that people fall through when
they go through this process first off
really the first person that you hire is
a good fit they may have the skills that
you want but your values don't align
right you don't have similar one words
you haven't gone through that process
your values on the line and so falls
apart you also likely suck as a leader
part of now building a team is you need
to lead
you'd be good manager you have to care
about your people not just about them
getting the work done but care about
them as human beings and what they going
through and how you can help they can be
supportive to them so a lot of times
that first hire doesn't work out and
here's what happens to so many
entrepreneurs that person didn't work
out I can't build a team that was a
stupid idea I'm just going to go back to
doing everything myself because it was
so much easier and then you end up
playing small again so what ends up
happening when you hire is they take a
ball out of your time there's a learning
curve so you may have some problems at
the beginning but by working through
that and maybe getting rid of them and
bring you somebody else in work it
through that getting the right people in
place that's when you can go and explode
and do much more meaningful work spend
your times when the things that make you
a lot more excited and have a much
bigger impact a lot of people also say
well I don't have the money to go and
hire somebody I can't afford the growth
and hire somebody how am I going to
build a team you know I can't even pay
myself a couple ideas one you don't
necessarily need to hire somebody right
now as long as it's on your roadmap a
lot of help today you're constantly
paying attention to that is in your
vision so that you're not going to be
doing this alone for the rest of your
life - you can look at hiring somebody
on a part-time basis the first person I
hired was for one hour a day one hour
day is doing database work for me
because he was better at it than I was
and he freed up an hour and a half of my
time to go off and do other things that
I enjoyed more and I was better at and
could help build the business you could
hire somebody for an hour a day or a
couple hours a week just to free up some
of that work that you don't want to do
to focus on bigger things a tree you can
also look for people to volunteer to be
a part it might be a partnership in your
business and you're both putting sweat
equity in it might be mentoring somebody
who is a high school intern or
university intern and bringing them into
your business now you have to do your
job of actually mentoring them but
they're looking more for the experience
of being involved in what you're doing
then for monetary compensation right
they're getting the grade at their
school so they have to do a good job and
that's what they're looking for much
more than getting paid to do it so
there's always other options and one of
the most important things that you need
to under
entrepreneur is you need to be
resourceful you will get these kinds of
problems
constantly I need to bring on a team but
I can't afford to do it how do I do that
I need to go and market my company but I
can't afford to take out an ad on the
Superbowl so how do I go and do that
right you will constantly have these
restrictions and restraints that are put
on you as you try to build a business
you are constantly lacking in resources
and so you succeed by being resourceful
by finding another way by being creative
by understanding people and what they
need and how you have to give to them in
a non-monetary way that's the game of
entrepreneurship I was able to greatly
expand my businesses like my youtube
channel since that's what you're maybe
more familiar with at the beginning it
was me doing videos all by myself and I
would make a video you know at most once
a week but usually maybe once a month or
twice a month and then as I brought my
first editor on board
that's when is able to go from once a
week max to once a day that was a huge
increase right seven times or more and
then when I got a second editor when I
got researchers I can move up and with
the two-a-day and with the three a day
and so you can greatly improve your
productivity by building the team and I
get to focus on what I love doing I
don't like getting it's not what I love
Christina
loves editing Christina data in this
video when I love you Christina
Christina loves evident what she'd love
to do which is great at it's amazing I
love being in front of the camera and
it's the highest value that I can bring
to the team if we've relied on me being
a great editor this company would fail
because it's not something I actually
want to learn to get better at this is
all saying if you want to go far you go
with team if you want to go fast you go
alone and so stop focusing on the
short-term game of just 45 think long
term things bigger picture thinks going
far think about the vision think about
you're trying to accomplish you need a
team to help you get there so the
question today today is I'm curious who
was the first person that you hired on
your team that added incremental
improvement and you saw big business
growth because of it
or if you haven't hired yet who is the
first person that you need on your team
to be able to do blast through really
curious to find out
leave it down the comments below I also
want to give a quick credit to coach
Bailey Cooper from canvassing coach
Austin Tx calm thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I really really really appreciate
the support and I hope you're enjoying
the reason so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you
I hope we're getting you to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Press
[Music]
over the next five years we plan to take
on the banking community we plan to take
on the cosmetics industry we plan to
take on the clothing industry and
telecommunications and one or two other
industries and see whether we can give
them a run for their money
and do it slightly differently than it's
been why do you think you can do it
mainly because I think we've got a
fantastic team of people we attract good
people and their skills are translatable
to whatever the industry is its
creativity its risk orientation it's
what I think if you can run if you can
run one business well you can run any
business and if you know that what
matters and business is a good team of
people well motivated team with people
and sendeth I as well giving a lot of
freedom to go out and improve themselves
you can pretty well achieve anything
what do you credit
we just expect when you gotta have a
great team so by having the right people
around you surprise prize mother night
of turnout is just be myself
both were solid workers but also just
positive influences to you you know niku
that inspire you to bring good energy
every day that and you you know hard
work and dedication you sounds so
passionate about so many diverse pieces
of your life that the big question is
you juggle all that like how do you make
all of that happen and successfully from
your music career to being a mom to
being a life partner to like all of that
is so hard to juggle how do you do it
with the secret behind that I don't know
how when I keep doing it a good question
because with the baby things things tend
to change a lot but you know have a
great team people who understand me very
well who understand my cause my my
commitments and and who support him and
make my life easier so it is very
important to be well surrounded